I think woke is cluster B I think woke
is cluster B I think another term I
think there are a number of terms that
we use in different contexts that all
point to the same fundamental reference
okay so let's let's just call it the
referent I'm not even going to say that
cluster B is the base cluster B is one
term to describe the referent the actual
phenomenon itself or the set of
phenomena sometimes we call it cluster B
sometimes we call it woke sometimes we
call it cult Dynamics sometimes we call
it political
authoritarianism um number of different
ways I believe all of those things are
pointing to the same underlying
psychological mechanisms the same states
of mind the same broken states of mind I
think this
because um I used I used to be somebody
that you would have called
woke I um and I I what I'm about to say
I offer descriptively it is not
judgmental toward anyone else it's
simply to let people know where I'm
coming from and why I say what I
say I was a leftist a a card carrying
Democrat all of my adult life I was a
progressive leftist I wasn't just a
center-left person I was on the woke
side um I got my
start
in well things were different in those
days but when I was 16 years old I was
already becoming a local celebrity in my
town I was the poster boy for a new
ordinance a gay rights ordinance in
Syracuse New
York uh that would have it did
successfully pass it made it illegal
within the city of Syracuse to fire an
employee simply on the grounds of
homosexuality I had run into that
problem at my grocery store employer
and um I I had come out unusually early
in those days I was about 13 when I came
out publicly in in the mid to late 80s
which was not very common in those days
um and I
was I be I was I don't want to eg it but
I was used um by political activists who
saw an articulate young
man uh who was not afraid to talk to the
camera I made a great poster boy for
this this campaign right so I've been
doing leftist politicking for a very
long time I I no longer consider myself
a leftist I did not go and join the
Republican party I'm not a card carrying
member of any party um most people on
the left would describe me today as a
conservative
um uh but the these these these words
and definitions are are often they're
tools and weapons against people rather
than they are enlightening descriptors
so um people will describe me however
they want but I'm certainly not a
leftist I'm not a
liberal um
and that changed for me only seven years
ago this is recent I'm 49 today this
started happening when I was about 41
years
old um and I I'll do this briefly and
I'll also preface this by saying to
anyone listening I am doing this
descriptively because I want you to
understand my thought process this is
not fishing for sympathy I do not ask
for nor do I want people to think of me
as somebody they need to say I'm so
sorry um you know oh what a horrible
life you had I'm not looking for
sympathy I'm not fishing for any
emotional support from anyone this is
simply
descriptive my mother as I alluded to
before my mother is deranged she's not
just a not great mother she is
deranged and for those she has what I
call a combination of borderline and
narcissistic personality disorders I
also I believe she also has context
dependent sociopathic
traits I did did not recognize this
until I was about 41 years
old
um our childhood growing up was a
mixture
of I'll put it to you this way those of
you of a certain age probably 40 or
older I'm getting older now and so my
cultural references don't hit younger
Generations anymore I can't help that
I'm sorry I don't know your world and
you don't know mine um but if you want
to know the kind of person that my
mother that her children experienced
I'll give you two movie characters and
ask you to make a composite out of them
Joan Crawford and Mommy Dearest and
Margaret White the mother in the horror
film Carrie the religious fanatic mother
if the people who have seen these movies
and understand those cultural references
my mother was a combination of these two
people um if that sounds extreme and if
people are are are want to react by
saying oh but those movies were so
ridiculous
I can tell you from my point of view I
didn't see anything in either of those
movies that struck me as unbelievable or
extreme I saw things in those movies
that look like the interior of our home
okay those mothers exist they're not one
in one million either thank God they're
not they're not one in five but they
sure as hell are not one in a million
and they're not even one in a hundred
there's a lot more of them than that so
let me just say I believe such mothers
would have been vanishingly rare in the
ancestral past that in a harsh
environment in which food is limited and
the ability to partner with people was
the difference between uh persisting
through tough times and
starving there would have been a strong
selective
Force against pathology that
severe um you know a self-terminating
strategy I would say yeah that that yeah
what we have is a society that has
produced such
excess that it allows patterns that
would otherwise have self-terminated to
persist and so what we see is those
patterns spreading especially since um
they are
transmissible absolutely absolutely
so what what that meant was that my
childhood was filled with it half of our
childhood my brother and sister and
I um was my mother and my violent uh
stepfather so there was also an abusive
personality disordered father figure in
the house
um uh but the majority of our childhood
he was not part of that picture that was
a five to six year period and then he
was put out of the house so that was
early rather than late yeah for me it
was between the ages of five and um no
four years old and uh 9 to 10 years old
that that my stepfather was part of our
lives so short in duration or
comparatively short in duration but in a
phase when it was liable to have the
biggest developmental effect yeah I mean
as an example you know we three children
watched him try to murder my mother so
that is the kind of childhood that I had
and yes it's extreme I know it's extreme
but it is not as rare as your audience
thinks it is it it really isn't I'm I'm
glad that it's not common but these
things don't just take place on what we
used to call movie of the week right um
that's the childhood that I grew up in
that distorted me severely
psychologically um I I am a typical
outcome of that childhood there's
nothing unusual about the person that I
became I have struggled with major
clinical depression I've been diagnosed
with panic disorder um major clinical
depression obsessive compulsive disorder
uh Tourette's like tick symptoms um I
spent 22 years as a severe alcoholic and
self-destructive I'm not I'm not an
alcoholic anymore the I am common I am a
typical run-of-the-mill outcome of that
kind of
childhood I didn't know what was wrong
with my family until I was 41 years old
and after an extended period of not
living physically close to my mother and
that part of the family I brought her
back into my life I bought a house for
her to live in as she retired and got
older it was a very I made a series of
very bad mistakes and within two years
everything that all of the insanity of
my childhood was now back in my face in
my 40s and in bright Living Color and I
had told myself a fairy story that if I
could solve my mother's chronic poverty
and my and my mother's chronic um need
to feel safe and protected if I could do
that if I could give her this affordable
place to live and solve that problem
then she'd become the calm and nurturing
person that she really was
underneath
no so so so just to fill that in for uh
people for whom this is a new topic
you're laughing now because that is a uh
implausible thought psychologically
speaking given the nature of these
disorders yes correct um the they don't
get better most for the most part um it
was such a crisis at 4 one that I I had
what we colloquial call colloquially
call a nervous breakdown it was a it was
a turning point in my life and I had to
make a decision and the decision I made
uh was to sue my mother and evictor from
my house and to put her out of my life
entirely it was the very hardest most
painful and brutal year of my life but
it was also the best thing that ever
happened to me it set me free for the
first time in my life so I that's when I
learned what cluster be was I I finally
had a taxonomy and a system that could
explain to me what I had always thought
of as my mother's peculiar Insanity that
I can never explain to anyone else I
realized that there there actually was
an explanation for it but very quickly
after coming to that realization and
deciding that I would no longer have
that as part of my domestic life I
looked around and I
said good God almighty this is happening
in the world around me and not only is
it happening in the world around me it's
my friends it's my political tribe it's
the people that I've been hanging around
with I have surrounded myself with
people who are acting out a version of
my childhood it rocked me Brett to my
core it it destabilized everything I
thought was true about the
world over seven
years that led me to my current view
that cluster be style emotion cluster be
style Psych iology and victim games that
I knew well from home have become
normalized and are woke this is woke the
screaming people out on the street you
we remember this from 2016 during the
Donald Trump election now I did say you
I remind everyone I already did
stipulate that I believe that Donald
Trump is himself a clinical narcissist
so uh you know even if you are some of
you in the audience are emotionally
reacting to me right now because you may
not like that I'm saying some very not
nice things about lots of left stuff I
also recognize the problem on the other
side too but the reaction we had to that
the reaction I had to it Brett here I'll
I I'll tell you I'll tell you what I did
election night
2016 I stayed up all night
crying crying that Donald Trump was
elected crying that this horrible man
was going to
um yes it's embarrassing of course it's
histrionic it was an absolutely
emotionally histrionic reaction and it
was not an intellectual
reaction I was still stuck this was just
the beginning of my coming out of of who
I was as a person back then but you saw
this you saw people on the street
literally screaming at the top of their
lungs in genuine emotional distress
toddler level emotional distress that's
extreme but that's an example um
histrionic or borderline personality
style Behavior inability to regulate
emotions um exaggerated emotions and
then I I began to see that all of these
people that you know I went to Sarah
Lawrence College um I was a card
carrying liberal decolonized this you
know white people are terrible men are
all misogynists this was me right I
regurgitated this bile most of my life
um it's clear to me now that this is a
case of reversal it's a case of
narcissistic reversal if you want to
point to the to the one trait the one
characteristic that almost always
indicates at least cluster be style
thinking even if we're not to say that
this person has a
disorder reversing the truth is the key
black is white bitter is sweet good is
bad ugly is beautiful that's woke woke
has reversed everything so
we have organizations like BLM that
claim to be full of victims of racism
who are actually abusive and and very
obviously some of them Psychopathic
they're burning buildings down right
endangering the lives of people burning
down unabashedly racist unabashedly
racist but they project it onto other
people they say you are doing this to me
you the white man are doing this to me
you the white woman are doing this to me
um trans is the same thing it is now
abuse we actually normal people normal
people who show up on shows like Good
Morning America and ABC Nightly News and
and the New York Times and
MSNBC allegedly normal people say as if
it were
normal that the people who are trying to
stop boy children from having their
testicles taken off and trying to stop
girl children from having their breast
sliced off the people trying to stop
that are the abusers who are killing
those children it is it is if I were a
religious person I say this on the show
it is satanic it is satanic in its
reversal it is the LIE it is the
original lie and it is wicked and evil
we are living in a Land of complete
moral and conceptual inversion that I
believe is what characterizes our woke
era yeah there is something powerfully
upside down about it it's not just
nonsense it's the inverse of the truth
and it
is ironically
imperiling the system that has offered
the best hope of any system in history
of actually leveling the playing field
yes it is it is it is destroying the
Cure in a
false
and uh
implausible quest to cure the disease
with the
poison yes and it's
it's it's bad it's it's much worse I
think some I think I think more people
are starting to see how bad it is but
even just a couple of years ago I I you
know I can I'm sure that you can I'm
sure that there's a if you will an
empathic way that you can connect to
this I'm betting that you you have
experienced some of this in your own
sphere um
um so I sometimes I still I I it's like
for a moment I forget that the world is
what it is and I I forget and I think
that it's it's the normal world that I
used to think existed and I'm shocked
awake and I say oh my this is really
happening this is actually happening
we're actually calling this the mangala
level mutilation of children we're
actually calling that love we're calling
it care this is real Josh you're not
having a nightmare you're actually awake
you're living a nightmare yes it's it is
literally a nightmare and I I say this
without without conscious hyperbole I
don't mean to exaggerate this I mean
this very plainly we are living in a
dystopian science fiction film it's not
coming it's already here yes it's here
and it has captivated institutions with
a great deal of power which is
terrifying now I do believe that
something tactical on what I call the
blue
team has come to understand that as much
as it wished to suppress discussion of
this pathology it has failed for the
same reason that it failed to enforce
its
Orthodoxy um through the mainstream
media because we found places to discuss
this that were not under its control and
as much as it tried to stamp them out it
failed in this case still trying oh
still trying and with respect to the
woke nonsense it is also still trying
but the fact is people reasonable people
people with common sense people who are
able to extrapolate properly have been
discussing this pathology have stared
down the stigmas that are used to
silence them and many people are now
awake at least
partially to the
paradoxes and the absurdity
of for example mutilating children in
the Name of Love yep um so that has
caused I believe a tactical shift on the
blue team which is staring at a election
picture that threatens to upend their
control and they are creating
distance with um
wokeism I believe it's purely cynical
and strategic okay um and in fact one
thing that I have faced which viewers of
Darkhorse uh will
recognize is that the those on the blue
team who are attempting to distance
themselves from woke for electoral
reasons have a problem which is that
there are people like Heather and me who
have been trying to call attention to
this horror who are on the left yep and
they do not wish to empower us
oh no right they do not wish to right
they they
absolutely uh see it as an existential
threat if they have to admit that we
were right then they will have to listen
to us on other topics like the horror of
the vaccination campaign that they have
just deployed so they have now um
arranged a narrative in which Once Upon
a Time um I was a decent chap teaching
at a college
who did correctly spot the problem of
woke and then went insane right that's
the narrative um so anyway I don't mean
to descend down that rabbit hole but I
just want to point out do expect woke to
um be deemphasized by those who have
been pushing it and expect them to bend
over backwards really believed that you
know we know you know there were some of
us who really went extreme and we
probably should have we probably should
have has spoken up a little bit more
about that but that was never the the
heart of our program and you know as as
M you know with all due respect to
people like Heather hying and and and
Brett um you know while they had a point
in the beginning they didn't stay on the
side of sanity and what we need right
now what we all need right now is just
to really calmly just understand that
there's truth on both Sid yeah I know I
can write the whole goddamn thing yep
yeah it's happening every single day I
mean look
you know you of course everybody knows I
know this I mean I I didn't know who you
were the first time I heard your name
and saw your face was was um in
documentaries about the Evergreen Fiasco
that threw you and Heather
out um obviously I stayed and paid
attention um but in a in a much less
dramatic and smaller
venue I lost my career of 20 years it's
it's coming up on a year that um I was
forced out of my job as the 20-year
director of a nonprofit Consumer
Protection Organization by a coup within
the organization a leftist coup within
the organization to smear my name to
extort donors and say um they lined up
Don uh are major donors pulled out if
you don't fire Joshua slokum and make a
public statement disavowing him for what
he does in his private time and his
political views we're going to bankrupt
the organization to pull out our
membership all that dirty was
pulled and um
as as I'm sorry most of these nonprofits
are in fact leftist even when they call
themselves
nonpartisan as leftist organizations do
they left they left me to hang out to
dry so yes I did actually resign rather
than being fired but had I not resigned
I would have been fired three days later
and I would have had no leverage at all
so let's let's Phill if assuming you're
willing let's fill that in a little bit
so people understand what you had
dedicated your life to that you were
tossed out for uh political
incorrectness yeah yeah can you describe
your your uh your work yes I spent 20
years as the executive director of a
nonprofit organization called funeral
consumers Alliance yes I realize that
sounds strange I asked people think of
it like it was the Consumer Reports
Magazine but only for the funeral
purchase the goal of the organization
was to educate the public because the
the funeral indust funerals and Cemetery
sales are more than2 billion dollar a
year in this country we spend a great
deal of money burying our debt thousands
of people every year feel that they have
been overcharged that it's burdensome
expensive and that they have to make
very consequential financial decisions
on the worst day of their lives without
sufficient information and time to make
those decisions so fca's goal was to
give people factual information about
their legal rights factual information
so they could evaluate the e economic
value of what they were asking for so
they could shop around and we also
lobbied on behalf of consumers for
regulations that would better protect
the public from predatory sales
practices so you were working to protect
the public from an industry that takes
advantage of people's grief that
financially takes advantage of people's
grief and even in that context you were
effectively thrown out because of
political differences that had nothing
to do with this correct I I started with
Kevin Kevin uh the other half of
disaffected this show was his idea this
this this is his baby uh he talked me
into it um we started the show we've
been talking about this hypothesis from
day one the very first episode in late
January of 2021 we said it explicitly
we're living in a cluster be
world I knew when I started that I did
know that the likely outcome was going
to be that I was going to be pushed out
of my job this was too too important I
wasn't willing to keep my mouth
shut um it took about a year and a half
but it happened and why did it happened
what happened the same story that you've
been through Brett the same story that
anybody else working for an any
organization that doesn't explicitly
disavow woke um non this nonprofit had a
lot of very good people a lot of very
charitable kind-hearted volunteers but
it was extraordinarily heavily weighted
toward hard leftism
and then it began to be taken over by
the set most known for woke the HR women
the millennial white women yes
women um who get their jollies and their
kicks by canceling other people smearing
their reputations and looking like lady
Bountiful most gracious mama in the
world who cares about all her little
children of all Races and all the
genders and this that and the other
thing these people whether they're men
or women these are not kind people
they're not good people they are
narcissists they are exploitative some
of them not all some of them are
sadistic as hell and they like hurting
other people they like taking their jobs
away from them that is what happened to
me so let me just point out the the
larger pattern here because yes I I have
lived it in a very different form y the
tragedy of what happened in Evergreen
was that Evergreen was exactly the right
place if you were a student who was not
a good fit for a normal College
environment but had high potential yeah
there are a huge number of those people
who need a place like Evergreen and what
the woke activists did by creating a
riot around a phony claim of racism
largely against me was destroy the place
so that it now does not exist in any
meaningful sense it still hobbles along
with huge State subsidies but the fact
is it is not capable of doing the job of
educating that it once was and so the
point is in a
symbolic um
Hemorrhage ostensibly about protecting
oppressed people it hurt people who were
actually benefiting from something in
your case your organization was
protecting consumers from a predatory
industry those consumers were hurt by a
internal woke
takeover that had nothing to do with
funeral services or the funeral industry
right it was petty and harmful to the
exact people the organization was
designed to help and I know other cases
let me tell let me tell you how harmful
sure
right there's there's no staff in the
organiz a anymore the office is closed
when I left within four or five months
of my leaving they eliminated the second
staff position they closed down the
office now there are some volunteers who
are still trying to keep it going but
they allowed they allowed and if any of
them are watching I am talking to you
and about you you allowed Wicked people
who did not have your constituency's
best interests at heart to push you into
pushing me out at the expense of the
organization and now it's it it exists
on paper only you know this isn't I'm
not even bitter about this anymore I'm
glad I'm out of that that now but yes
they left Evergreen and tatters my
organization was left practically
non-existent this happens to group after
Group after group College after college
after college it never works out to
anyone's benefit except the people at
the at the heart of these campaigns
except the petty
tyrants um and I will just say we also
uh have a close friend who um literally
had an organization that he
founded uh brought to its knees over
his his uh willingness to acknowledge
his friendship to fail to
disavow Heather who is oh I'm sure
deemed to be a trans fol which she is
not um so anyway the point is this was
an environmental organization and a good
one most of them are not this was a good
one that was actually doing real good in
the world and the point is what was the
consequence of this woke campaign it was
a setback for the environment your
example is a setback for consumers who
are going to face this predatory
industry without anyone looking out for
their interests my situation was a
setback for the students who were
benefiting from an educational
environment that could actually pay
attention to their individual needs yes
let me this this is an excellent place
to insert this I think to tie some
Concepts together for people this is a
perfect example of our my thesis and
Kevin's thesis that as in the home so in
society this does scale from domestic
abuse to public life so a domestically
abusive family a family with a
borderline or a narcissist parent at the
core that is a cluster B family even
though the children don't have
personality disorders every single
member of that family is playing a role
in a cluster B scripted drama play one
of the roles one of the most common
roles that children play and other
family members play uh that you call it
you become what they call a flying
monkey for the narcissist and it's a
reference to the uh to The Wizard of Oz
the witch didn't do her own Dirty Work
she had an army of monkeys with wings
that she sent out to poison Dorothy and
the Scarecrow and all this other stuff
so you become a flying monkey for the
narcissist for the pathological person
you believe that they are actually the
victim they claim to be you believe
their stories that the people around
them are hurting them and that you out
of loyalty feel that you need to go
defend mom or dad um and how it works in
the family I was a flying monkey for my
mother for decades my mother had me
convinced that my sister was clinically
insane it was actually my mother not my
sister I abused my sister at my mother's
behest I didn't think I was abusing her
I didn't think I was mistreating her but
I didn't believe her I called her a liar
um it's sick it's grotesque you know I
mean I there's some things that I've
done and that anyone in a family like
this has done that are very shameful but
this is what happens this is happening
too the friend the person at the
environmental organization who would not
disavow friendship with Heather was
being a flying monkey for a narcissist
or a pathological person to EXA in
exactly a parallel way to the way
children are conscripted to abuse their
siblings
this is how it scales well he refused to
be a flying monkey okay which cost him
his
organization you're gonna be punished
one way or another yeah yeah um that
which is a you know that is a a
insightful and terrifying portrait that
you paint right it also means that one
has to be careful to uh understand that
the source of the abuse that they are on
the wrong end of may or may not be the
person delivering it correct right that
person may be under a
[Music]
misapprehension